thank you Peter and good afternoon to
everybody as I think you'll have seen
from Michael's presentation I have taken
my role at Yale to try and get every
single part of the University working
towards Himalaya gun and to that end I
have the pleasure of working with trip
and and Peter and many others on a new
course so I'm going to speak just for a
few minutes and then pass over to trip
and talk you through really what we've
been doing with a a new class that we're
in the middle of right now this is quite
experimental for us also so if it's a
bit basic then please indulge us the
idea for a course using yells
collections of Himalayan materials came
out of an exhibit that I co-curated here
at Yale in the Sterling library early
this year with two colleagues Sarah
Calhoun who is also in the library
responsible for South Asian collections
and a faculty member Andrew Quint Minh
in religious studies Yale has
extraordinarily rich and deep and rather
understudied collections of him Lane
materials we thought it would be fun to
pull a few of these together in an
exhibit and see what conversation came
out of it what came out of it was that
we realized we can actually do something
much more ambitious with the collection
and teach a class so I've been battling
in my two and a half years at Yale with
a problem these wonderful final papers
come into my inbox in the class and I
grade them and they often do very well
because the students are fantastic but
what happens with them afterwards some I
believe should have an afterlife there's
something in these papers that is
interesting and usable but they don't
have any traction they end with the
class and of course students at Yale are
accomplished in writing final papers I
mean they got in because they're
wonderful synthesizers of other people's
information right wonderful analytical
skills but how can you move beyond it
and my idea in discussion with trip and
many other colleagues was to actually
develop a hands-on and truly
collaborative class we could perhaps
explore the links between yells
collections that are drawn from or about
the Himalayan region and as a result
actually do something that would have an
after life beyond the class produce
crowd
sourced richer catalog descriptions for
these collections I should be clear
we're talking about art in the galleries
materials beautiful illuminated Tibetan
manuscripts in the by Nicki missionary
collections in the Divinity School and
also collections in the Sterling library
of the first ambassador US ambassador to
Nepal though many of these catalogs many
of these folders just say 12 letters or
23 photographs could we do something
with these collections and at the same
time could we fold back that which we
learned the class work itself into the
online catalog at Yale make it visible
make it discoverable of course something
like this is experimental it's
challenging for students to work with
primary materials often for the first
time in their academic careers it's hard
for them to evaluate and triage
different sources of information what is
legitimate what has Authority how do you
compare a book with a missionary
manuscript with a photograph and all the
time they're bothered by one thing which
is professor are you saying that people
will see this after i have left yale in
other words yes you may actually have a
trail that that extends beyond you it's
possible here because we have these
world-class and rather underutilized
collections because thanks to the
ex-president former president of Yale
Rick Levin we have a very generous open
access policy that that says everything
we've got at Yale in cultural heritage
should be available to all we also have
funding available through different
streams within IT and Library Services
to actually encourage faculty to engage
with technology in the classroom and
then we have many of you archivists
curators librarians instructional
technologists who are just excited to
collaborate in the pedagogy of a
classroom so far the students love it
but they find it really challenging
together we're actually learning our way
around the whole Yale campus thanks to
the wonderful Yale shuttle service
because many undergrads don't really
make it up to divinity during their time
here unless they have good cause and at
the same time we're discovering that we
as a community of staff faculty and
students are collaborating about how
knowledge is shared produced and
understood
it's generated lots of interests among
sort of the Yale undergraduate body the
newspapers I'm constantly getting emails
from people saying how are you doing
this and why are you doing this which i
think is also an excellent question some
of the challenges and surprises we faced
is that students we have here while
they're very good users of digital
content they're not always great
producers of it it's a different thing
to have to build a catalog than to use
one there's also a lot to learn and I
don't think we have enough time and a
core team well I'll come on to that in a
moment it's a very intense experience
for all of us working on this it's much
more work than any other class I've ever
taught so one question with that is is
it scalable and is it sustainable on
that note here we have the core team
myself Sara Calhoun I'd mentioned in the
library trip here Peter Leonard who
we've heard from of course and Luke
vogner a teaching fellow funded by the
graduate school there are other two
members who are not core who are not in
a full-time engaged and with this kind
of work Daniel hoo graphic designer in
New York and Chico utter a graphic
designer here at Yale who does wonderful
work and has helped us with our kind of
visual look and feel so with that I'm
going to hand over to trip thank you
Mark and in fact as I pull this up i
want to thank mark very much for
bringing this project to itg and for
giving me a chance to be a part of it
it's very exciting to bring all these
people together and to do some work so
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
technology and the environment
environment in a couple different senses
first of all mark mentioned the places
we've gone to this is the art gallery
the day mission library manuscripts and
archives were not physically in so I
don't have a picture of them and the
bind key and all these materials we've
been working with these different places
have different levels of digitization
that have come along with them we're
using o mecca for the platform it comes
out of the Center for history and new
media at George Mason University it's
well sustained by them it has been
called sometimes wordpress for libraries
and museums and that's roughly true but
one of the things that I've found so
far is that and this is my third time
using it in a roughly year long casual
pilot in a various classes is that
there's not as big a community around it
as there is with WordPress so some
things are limited they've migrated to a
new version recently and so there are
some limitations it also has a certain
sort of world view about what open means
it has made decisions that things are
very flat in no mecca and so there are
other tools out there that have
different permission systems that I'd be
interested in looking into in the future
and so I'm going to take you through
very quickly the sort of one drill into
the platform we're using just to get
into one students work and talk about
that just a little bit so this is our
home page we have this very nice poster
that checotah design marc was mentioning
her and these are a list of collections
so it has this model of items
collections exhibits these are some
collections that the students have put
together one of the students whose work
has been really nice is Courtney
Randolph who's done some work with going
coventry letters at the div school so
she enters this collection she answers a
lot of metadata and makes choices about
what goes into this this is a box that
has had some study done to it but as far
as I know she's not merely replicating
the work that's been done she's doing
her own unique work which is very nice
she has digitized a lot of the items
that were not previously digitized in
this box from the archives and each of
these items she's gone in further to
digitize I'll put one of those up she's
gone through each page of this and
photographed it and no that's just a
screenshot but these as well have their
own metadata for them so she has put all
of this together in an exhibit which
looks like this it looks a little bit
different from the main site and this is
just the front page and it's just a work
in progress she's done this as part of a
mini assignment that this is going to go
on to be the first stage of the final
assignment and I'm really impressed i've
liked very much the work that she's done
on this
this is the one screen of the admin side
of it and you can see all the
possibilities of use of this the
students are full administrators in this
site so they can go into it basically
and do what they want we have to give
them a bit of a talk just to say don't
delete other people's things if you ever
talk to anybody about oh Mecca sooner or
later you'll have somebody who said oh
yes you have to make your students
admins and one of them deleted every
other student stuff so fortunate we have
not had that yet they've been very
responsible so lots of people here work
with metadata so to some extent you know
what I might be getting to next but so
they the students have to make their
decisions of of this some of it they can
recapitulate from other existing sources
but some of it they have to come up with
their on that on their own and so one of
the nice things about it for me is that
it starts to articulate to the students
that there is Labor attached to all of
this there's an electoral labor there's
digital labor attached all of this I've
tried to foreground a critical
technology literacy with them admit it's
been a bit shallow so far but again as
Mark said it's a bit experimental we're
working this out and so when the
students come to this and have to start
entering things and what they see is
actually this not this small but they
see screens and screens and screens of
metadata and start having to think about
these things they they pick up on it and
and they realize just how much work
frankly in a sense how much work you and
we do on this stuff and they start
getting a sense of what the bigger
picture of digital scholarship and
curation and and an editorial work is
and its really remarkable the way the
students are picking up on that
you